at about 840 p.m. on thursday the 16th
of july the victim who we believe to be
mr. donald luck was driving south on the
a 24 when he struck the rear of a car
there was also straddling south just
past the junction with the black horse
pub mr. Locke got out of his vehicle and
was confronted by the driver of that
other vehicle who then stabbed him
repeatedly the offender then got back
into his car and drove south away along
the a24 mr. Locke suffered multiple stab
wounds and despite paramedics working on
him at the scene he died shortly
afterwards his attacker is described to
us as being white aged between thirty
and forty about six foot in height and
skinny build he had shoulder-length
brown or dark blond hair and a thin face
we have officers carrying out
house-to-house inquiries in the area
looking for anyone who could have any
information that could help us identify
exactly what happened last night we're
appealing to anyone who may have CCTV at
their home address or business that
covers the a24 between offing tenkara
roundabout at Worthing and the long
furling furlong roundabout at finden in
addition anyone that as a vehicle with a
dashboard camera on it who was in the
area at that time is asked to contact
the police we are looking for an
extremely dangerous man and we need the
public's help to identify him and arrest
emergently therefore I'm appealing to
anyone who has information about what
has happened to come forward and speak
to the police no matter how unimportant
you may think it is it may be that
provider piece of information we need
the attackers vehicle is likely to have
suffered minor damage to the rear end
and the attack himself is likely to have
substantial amount of blood on him after
the attack this could also be in his
vehicle I would ask anybody are you
suspicious of someone who has come home
after 840 p.m. last night and have blood
on them or were they acting suspiciously
or indeed were you expecting anybody
home last night who hasn't turned up if
anybody has any suspicions about anybody
please do not Chan
them but instead contact the police and
let us deal with it thank you